a lot of people in my workshops would
ask me about story structure and
originally the workshops were more about
what you know what we call the hidden
tools of comedy but the more I thought
about it the more I thought that there
was a very particular kind of story
structure in comedy my friend Chris
Vogler wrote this great book the writers
journey and the writers journey is a
take-off on the hero's journey Joseph
Campbell's hero with a thousand faces
and if you've seen Star Wars you've seen
a good example of the hero's journey the
the young protagonist who has greatness
within them and then there's a call to
action and then there's the refusal of
the call they meet the mentor and and on
and on and I and in thinking about it I
thought that there are a lot of
structures similar structures to comedy
but there are also very important
differences as well and so I started
working on this book called the comic
hero's journey and in the comic hero's
journey it starts sort of like the
hero's journey in in the normal world we
see the protagonist whether it's Bill
Murray in Groundhog Day or Melissa
McCarthy in spy we see them in their
normal world but the big difference one
of the big differences in the comic
hero's journey is that whereas in the
hero's journey the protagonist has
greatness within them only they don't
know it in the comic heroes journey
usually the protagonist does not have
greatness within them in fact the
protagonist has really messed up in a
spy Melissa McCarthy is self-doubting
she she's very beholden to what other
people think of her she really wants the
attention of her spy
Bradley fine played by Jude Law in
Groundhog Day Bill Murray's a jerk and
he's a
just just nowt creep who doesn't like
other people and doesn't care that other
people don't like him so in the comic
hero's journey you start with a
character who is in some way broken or
or flawed or there they have a hole in
them and but they don't know it they're
happy to be in their world they think
that whatever is happening in the world
is the way it's supposed to be and so
they have initial goals and in the in
the comic hero's journey
the initial goal is always something
short-sighted and soon to change in
Groundhog Day
Bill Murray simply wants to get a job at
a bigger television station right now
he's a newscaster weathercaster in
Pittsburgh and he wants to go to a
bigger television station in spy Melissa
McCarthy simply wants this gorgeous
James Bond Ian type of spy Jude Law to
fall in love with her and that's her
that's her fantasy that's her goal
you